welcome along i'll declare the
performance policy and partnerships
extraordinary meeting open
we have
apologies from councillor kit
mrs coote
and
potentially also councillor clark as
he's a submitter
and also welcome along councillor abbott
on zoom would somebody like to second
i'll move the apology second did
councillor scout put that all in favor
against carrie
there is one minor late item that we
need to accept and that is the
submission submission of mary mcfarland
it was received after the publication uh
of the agenda but it's easy enough for
us to incorporate it would somebody like
to move that's accepted councillor lewis
councillor edmondson thank you i'll put
that all in favor
aye against
carried a couple of uh alterations to
the schedule uh submitter number 21 june
trotter who was on the original schedule
i think as our last submitter has said
she no longer wishes to speak to a
submission obviously her written one
still stands
there are a couple of alterations from
people who were either going to be on
zoom and are now attending or were
attending and are now on zoom but that's
fine
um there might be the occasional period
where we have a an adjournment um
if we start to run ahead of time
otherwise
here we go uh we're grateful to all
those people who have taken the time to
submit
uh
just looking towards the back and
wondering if mr kennedy has arrived as
yet could be a slight delay to our start
dave kennedy from indicating public art
gallery
that's submission number 113
not here yet
right
excellent start we'll begin with an
adjournment and wait for his arrival
he won't be too far off come on
if the second submitter was here
i'd move to that
but i don't see noel in the waiting room
as yet
he's still wondering
no he won't be far away
arnold is in the waiting room
we might um
jump ahead to know actually
okay counselors i'll reconvene the
hearing uh no uh i thought you might be
ahead of time and thank you for your
punctuality um we've got a
a gap and would mind wonder if you would
mind starting a little early with your
submission
with us now
yes uh
thank you mr chair
um sorry i'll just have a little
technical issue but i'm no problem
um but um
thank you for um
giving me the opportunity to speak this
morning um
um welcome welcome um
everyone that's here
um
i i
think i've given you a fairly in-depth
um
vehicle a written submission so i'm not
going to dwell on
a lot of and talk this morning um but i
i just thought um a few points that i'd
run over and then i'm free for questions
i've i've had quite a few conversations
around the city
um with people both um great players and
and uh visitors and
i found um
etsy being around the old museum
building um
in the queen's park area um very useful
meeting up with people that were
wondering why the museum wasn't open or
or just uh wanted to say something about
it
and and what i i gained from talking to
over 20 people was that
the great majority of people are wanting
um council to get on with the project
and get um
a building up and running again so that
they've got a museum they can visit
um quite a few people that live in
nearby
towns to um in the cargo
and stated that they said you know we'd
come to them to capital at the museum
and
another bit of feedback was that
people seem to think that building
um big and new was um was um the best
option
and uh
some of them didn't really understand
why the old building couldn't be um
it wasn't a good option um
not that it couldn't be but that it
wasn't the best option or a good option
um they didn't understand that but i
don't think the message got across you
clearly on that but once i explained to
them that it really wasn't the best
option
and they were quite heavy with the you
know to go ahead with something bigger
so
um there was also um
i got my ear chewed by um
quite a few people that were concerned
about the cost um to rate payers
um and there was people that were
on fixed incomes and unbiblical times of
saying well
i just won't be able to pay it so
you'll see in my written submission the
suggestions there that
um you know
some form of rape relief or the fact
that you
attempt to gain some and greater amount
of external funding so that all the
burden doesn't fall on the right path
i think i think that would be important
and the three elephants that i see in
the room
um to the whole matter and as uh the
three waters transition i see in dunedin
there there
and you know going to spend quite a bit
of money upgrading the water before they
um transition into the
new authority and that all being that it
and goes ahead
and
covered and and climate change they're
all
unexpected um things that um could throw
a left ball at you
um as far as cost and
and social um harm so
you know
if we had another big covered outbreak
and even had people to come to the
museum um in the year that it's due to
the open will you know it could could be
an issue so but anyway
putting all those things
aside all the challenges i think that
you're doing a grand job of um
of
pressing ahead with
the museum and the annual plan in
general
and uh
congratulations to the
um staff that have researched it well
to the board members that have listened
and researched well and made good
decisions
so well done
and let's make tuna a reality that's
that's my verbal i'm open to any
questions that you wish thank you noel
and thank you for taking the time to
make a submission and speak to it uh i
note that in your submission and you
just um touched on it there uh in in
speaking to us
that
there uh
you're suggesting that council looks at
ways of um
providing rate relief for low income
earners
um
i'd be interested in hearing what
suggestions you have for those bearing
in mind that there is already a subsidy
available under a national framework for
people who um
qualify
yes i i
i'm i'm alluding to the um the existing
subsidy and and
i'm i'm actually a low income union
myself so
i'm in that i'm in that um
group of people
and uh you know unless i had to go and
ask the council was there um
a rape relief um
it's not promoted and i think there's a
lot of people out there that are
struggling and they don't actually even
realize that they can get a rebate on me
on their rights and
i think also the girl and council would
um pursue the possibility and i know i
realize it's an impossibility
of actually um increasing the um the
rate relief
um there's a lot of burden upon
um
rate payers from all sorts of directions
as we know
and uh it's not just the cost of the
rates um that's everything to do with
lying these days so
you know maybe i don't know how that
process works or how it's reviewed but
um
i just said yes that would be um worth
investigating that was my suggestion
thanks no um
the amount is actually set by by
government but just to reflect on what
you were saying your suggestion is that
we make sure there's uh additional
publicity to make people aware of it
yes and and maybe um put the word to the
government that maybe it's time to
review it again
thank you councillor pottinger
thank you chair
noel this question is regarding three
waters that you've
submitted on
with the formation of these four new
entities
um
do you have any fear
that a future government not necessarily
this cove
current government
may privatize
these entities because they're all
nicely bundled up now currently the 67
councils and the risk of privatization
is not even there but when you've got
four nicely packaged entities
a future government who's a bit short of
cash may
decide this is this is really good to
sell what's your view on that
yeah personally um
i'm counsellor i i don't have that fear
um
i'm being um told um
clearly that uh there's going to be um
things put in place so that that can't
happen and in fact um
the argument is that before entities
will make sure that that doesn't happen
so
unless he puts in an arms link from um
central government but um
i uh yeah no i don't i don't have any
fear of it so and i actually welcome the
whole process now the reason i ask that
is any new government can change the
rules as is the government now so yeah
that's the reason i was asking
yeah well our governments can also save
rules um they can cast them so that they
and can't be changed thank you
i'm okay thanks noah any other questions
if not thank you noel for your
submission and for your time this
morning we appreciate it
have a great day
got it
dave welcome along
come up take a seat
please yes
so kyoto koto i'm dave kennedy um i'm
the current chair of the indicator
public art gallery
our
boat members in their board
wanted to support the third option
for the museum the larger option
i think we stated their reasons that we
think that we should future proof our
facilities to make sure that the last
time in the past we've made decisions to
like the first original museum in 1941
intended to have an art gallery attached
and they ran out of money and do it
consequently we struggled to provide
that facility
and we also support the proposed change
the reserve status of the district
reserve
but just in speaking a bit further in
support of
the larger facilities
um
i just thought it was interesting if you
look at the four well-beings that um all
the local governments have to apply
cultural one is a really important one
and this
ensures that
the local community have got access to
cultural arts
and this is something that invercargill
has actually kind of struggled
to deal with
over time and i was just looking at
cities of a comparable sized indicator
or smaller
and most of them have quite a large
facility to exhibit art
for instance the new plymouth which is a
population a little bit bigger than the
carnival of scotland in lye centre
at the
connected art gallery pongarae the
population slightly bigger than the
vocabulary
art centre um
nelson
is slightly bigger than indicating
they've got this cedar gallery and out
of interest their connection art
connection
when we it has value the value of see
their collection with similar
size
and quality is
possibly depth quality in the cedar
gallery
our collection of art and indicators
has been
being told it's one of the more
significant regional collections and you
don't have a purposeful space to exhibit
it
the hastings city is um similar sized
indication they've got their city art
gallery uh hong kong sergeant they have
population smaller than the cargo timaru
thirty thousand it's got even thai
gallery cash burdens
so
we understand that the
aci the upset in the cargo is still at a
long term plan but it's some way off but
it's still doubtful that will go ahead
depending on
finances and so forth so we think it's
really important that any
museum facility
has
enough
space and capacity
to exhibit art
so that's why
the southern new zealand also has a
sizeable conventional large
and to me it makes sense that we
make sure that the public of indica and
also visitors are able to see the wealth
so
of course in support of the
new storage uh facility
that's in the open history
our collection is currently held in the
library there's only a temporary and
although we're really grateful to have
installed
in
proper
climate control conditions
um it is only a temporary space and
would love it to have a more permanent
homework
thanks dave councillors it's open for
questions
i guess your final comment dave
touches on the question that i was going
to ask and that was around
the uh desire of ipad to share that um
that that storage space at tisbury that
you see that is a
um a useful solution bearing in mind the
constraints you've got at
the archive now
i mean a number of years now we work
really well
with the museum and we see
the
looking at our collections
in the entirety means that we cannot
have kind of
collaborations that enable kind of
displays and things to use the wealth of
their conditions together i think
gallery currently is looking at um
getting online digitizing an entire
connection so it's available to the
public and we're also looking at
shifting a collection from
beehive which is
the
thanks councillor pottinger uh thank you
cheer dave
um
is it right you're opting for to the
larger museum yep yep cool
um my question is and there's probably a
tough one at this stage but it's worth
asking
is how many square meters would you like
allocated to art out of that you know
they've sort of in the plans and stuff
have shown how much would expect
to to get your
obviously your premium
stuff out there permanently
[Music]
you reckon there is enough space for
that i well i mean um we'd always like
to have more and i think probably the
way that we've been operating in hayward
has been kind of a little bit
experimental if you've got flexible
spaces and you're changing exhibitions a
lot you can accommodate you know a lot
of different kinds of exhibitions it
would be good to have
elements of our permanent collection on
display on a continual
basis can go along and see the quality
of their art but also have the potential
to have like touring exhibitions or
new and general exhibitions that may
combine
well there is i guess the reason for the
question was we're going to be debating
this option which option we want and is
is it big enough
um
well with my from the discussions that
we've had in the past probably what's
the
wouldn't be as big as we would want
just how many people sort of wonder
during the lunch time to see the
thank you
any further questions your worship
yes
i was just
wondering
about the
wow factor in terms of their art here in
the south
and i would say that gore's got it over
just about all of us at the moment but
in terms of the wow factory anyway
sorry your question
um how how do you feel about the um
core collection
um well i've actually worked quite
closely with easy southern gallery we
often share um connections and
exhibitions that they've put on but i'd
agree um
you know we've never had a herbivore
space
for art we were based at anderson house
and anderson house was a lovely building
in the lowly atmosphere that was nearly
built as an art gallery
limitations
so it would be lovely to have a space
that was
up there at least
as i said all those centres around in
the cargo similar size
quite substantial
thank you
any further questions for mr kennedy
if not thank you dave for the submission
from ipeg and for you for giving up your
time to come in and present this morning
we appreciate it
counselors i'm just going to take a
brief adjournment where we have an issue
with the live stream so we're going to
need to uh to restart it
anybody not catch that there may be a
fire alarms test
it is only a test
unless you smell smoke